Candid Truth
What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it. I cannot believe
how much of this stuff is coming out
left and right. The military is talking
about we see unidentified aerial
phenomenon in the sky. We don't know
what they are. We hear that they are
non-human intelligences, that they're
not alien, they could be
interdimensional because there's other
dimensions out there. Then there's a
quote-unquote whistleblower that comes
out and says I found a 20-ft egg-shaped
craft and I carried it with a
helicopter. It just keeps going, guys.
This guy, Chris Bledsoe, if you have not
seen the interview, it was on this show
Shawn somebody and in one day it got
over half a million views. Over half a
million views in one day. This is not
some fringy in the corner thing. This is
a huge deception that's coming right
now. And like all eyes are on this
thing. When you look at the
the comments under here, everybody's
saying things like finally, the world is
waking up. Like people are embracing
this whole UFO phenomenon like that this
is a spiritual awakening that we are
entering into the new golden age, the
age of Aquarius. All of this stuff has
been pre-planned for years and years.
Satan has been setting the stage to
appear as the cosmic Christ. But I want
you to hear from this guy because
he's a self-professed Christian. So this
is a little bit different than some of
the other people. I I haven't heard that
these other whistleblowers are
Christians. Lou Elizondo, you know, he
he says that Christians kind of have
their own way of looking at this thing,
but he doesn't believe that way. Um now
the last whistleblower, he was saying
things like he felt God and things like
that and he was wearing a hat that said
Trinity Aviation, which is a a very
openly Christian organization, uh
aviation company.
But this guy, he says, "I was raised
Baptist. When I got married to a
Pentecostal woman, I became
Pentecostal." He's very open about his
faith. He's very open that he believes
in Jesus, he believes the Trinity, he
believes in the Bible.
He believes all these things. Now
I want to hear what he's going to say. I
want you guys to hear what he's going to
say in this interview because this is
going to be the biggest deception in
human history. If we do not live by thus
saith the Lord, if we don't stand on the
truth, which is the word of God, we will
be taken over by this strong delusion,
by this mammoth deception that's going
to overtake us like an overwhelming
surprise.
We will not be able to withstand what we
see. We're going to see miracles, signs
and wonders, healings, all kinds of
supernatural things that we've never
experienced in our entire life. And
that's why Jesus said, "If they say he's
in If they say I'm in the desert, don't
go. If they say I'm in the secret
chambers, do not believe it."
Because it will be so overwhelming of a
deception that we will fall for it. Just
like Eve in the Garden of Eden when that
serpent seduced Eve into disobeying God.
In a perfect world, Eve was a perfect
being in a perfect world and he
masqueraded as this beautiful serpent in
the garden and was able to seduce her.
These creatures, Dad. These creatures,
why did you leave me? Why did you leave
me? I said, "I didn't leave you, son.
I've been gone for 20 minutes." He's,
"No, Daddy, you've been gone all night."
So this is He's talking about his
17-year-old son. He was out on a fishing
trip with some guys and his son, he
wandered off by himself because he's
dealing with Crohn's disease and he was
saying he was just spending time with
God and being like,
"What How am I going to provide for my
family?" And being overtaken by this
disease and all of a sudden he sees an
orange light in the sky. Then he sees
another one. Then he's hiding from this
orange light, but he decides to run and
right as he decides to run, a third one
appears right in front of him and he
kind of blacks out and when he comes to,
he's real close to his friends and the
fire has burnt out and he's saying, "You
guys won't believe what I just saw." And
they're like, "Dude, where have you been
all night?" He's like, "All night, I've
only been gone 20 minutes." But he sees
that the fire is out and his son is gone
and they said, "Your son is gone looking
for you." When he finds his son, his son
is in shock saying that he saw some
crazy creatures that just terrified him.
And we're going to let him continue the
story. What he saw were these two little
glowing beings that were yay high.
Probably three, two and a half, three
feet tall. And they had these bright red
eyes. And the whole time one was staring
at him. He couldn't shout. He couldn't
move. He He was in such terror, he was
frozen. And I don't know if they had the
power to keep him from He thought that
they had that power over him.
So this to me sounds like sleep
paralysis 101. Like he's describing
these short beings, which none of this
is lining up with a biblical description
of an angel. He's talking about these
three-foot beings with
glowing skin and red eyes. Um but it
terrified his son. It put him in so much
shock, it had control over him where he
couldn't even move.
That sounds like sleep paralysis to me,
which I know is a demonic entity. The
thing about the demonic world is Satan
and his demons have no dominion over us.
They have no power over us unless we
give the enemy an open door. And that
can come in the form of many different
things. If you have idols in your home,
you got a Buddha statue because you
think it looks cool or you got a a dream
catcher in your home, you need to get
these things out of your house. If you
have some kind of crystals or any type
of thing that's related to new age or
secular movies and and music,
anything like that, you need to get that
out of your home because you are
inviting the enemy into your house and
into your personal being.
When we begin to be mesmerized by these
things, if we see glowing lights in the
skies and we're like, "Oh, I wish I
could get a closer look." Guess what?
That thing's going to give you a closer
look. Just like when you pull out the
tarot cards, now all of a sudden Satan
says, "Oh, they're inviting me in. I
will appear as a dead loved one." Do not
mess with divination. If you pull out a
Ouija board, that is a sign to the
spirit world, "They're giving me access
into their life. I will deceive them
now." So when you see glowing things in
the sky, don't pursue them. Don't talk
to them and say, "I wish I could see
that thing."
These are not visitors from other
worlds. These are not physical beings.
These things defy physics on from all
accounts and they appear when people
meditate. People go into a field and
meditate and say, "I want to see you.
Show yourself to me." And all of a
sudden they show up. And people really
believe that these are beings from
millions of light years away that just
happen to show up because someone is in
a field meditating. It doesn't make
sense. This is spiritual. These things
go through walls. They go through They
abduct people through the ceiling of
their roof. All kinds of stuff. This is
a a demonic deception. It is sitting
there. Looks like a football now. It's
going white. It changed from red to
white and it's sitting sideways in the
road. It's hovering about five feet off
the ground and it looks like a an egg or
a football.
Did you catch what he said? The
description of the ship that he saw. He
said it looked like a football, a red
football, but then it transformed into a
white egg. Mm are we remembering
something that we just talked about?
There's a video, if you haven't checked
it out, go check it out under the videos
tab, not the live tab. And it's a
whistleblower, a supposed whistleblower
on mainstream media that is saying that
he obtained a 20-ft egg-shaped craft.
Here's the um here's the video clip.
Check this out. that made its way to the
ground on this particular operation. I
start feeling extremely emotional. And
the closer I get, the more the emotion
starts to overwhelm me. I feel this
intense hybrid of sadness and happiness
and beauty and song and I began
wondering what was wrong with me. As I
came over this object for the pic, it
was this overwhelming sense of emotion.
Is it your feeling? No, I felt like
something connected with me. I felt like
something had tuned in to me and my soul
and was providing me some sense of
guidance on what to do and how profound
what I was doing was. And it was so
overwhelming that I began to cry and I
got the load hooked up and I began
flying away. Once it was just me and
that object, I felt like something was
inside of me. I felt like I was
possessed by the most
beautiful spirit I'd ever been possessed
by and
Was it loving? It was loving.
But there was a sense of sadness at the
same time. Had you ever had an
experience like this before? No.
No, it was a very feminine energy, I'll
tell you that. I It felt like felt like
the spirit of God, but not in any
masculine sense. And it wasn't like a
soul, it was like a frequency that I was
connected with. And whatever that force
was, since that night, it has stayed
with me. And as crazy as this sounds,
it's what's guiding me now and it's
what's providing protection for me. It's
changed your life.
It's changed my life.
It's changed my life. It's made him
emotional to the point of feeling
overwhelming joy to the point of tears.
He's crying. He's having all these
emotions over this white egg that he
obtained and he was He's It's possessing
me. It's come inside me. It's with me to
this day and it's a it's a divine
feminine being, a divine feminine
spirit. This is exactly what we're going
to hear in this Chris Bledsoe case. It
is lining up perfectly.
This is Satan's final masquerade. He's
going to deceive the entire world and
all the stories are lining up. The stage
is being set for Satan to come as the
cosmic Christ.
At that moment,
it spoke to me
telepathically or whatever
and said, "You need to not worry about
her. She's in She's in good hands."
As humanists friends are are fleeing the
scene because they keep seeing these
beings or these orbs,
he's saying, "I'm not even scared
anymore because I've already had this
encounter with it, but these guys are
freaking out." And as they're driving,
they go past this hairpin curve and he
sees where his former wife passed away.
She wrecked into that spot and for years
he's been beating himself up over this
like, "I should have been there. I
should have I could have prevented her
from dying." And just him looking at
that spot, these beings telepathically
spoke to him and said, "Don't worry
about her. She's in good hands now."
So, if you understand what happens when
you die, the dead are dead. When Christ
returns, it says the dead in Christ will
rise first. In that moment, that's when
they're changed in a moment in twinkling
of an eye and and put on immortality.
The dead know nothing. The dead praise
not the Lord. The dead are sleeping
until that resurrection, but these
beings are telling him, "She's in good
hands." So, for right away, they're
lying. They're deceptively telling him a
lie and he's getting some kind of peace
that he's been searching after ever
since this has happened. He's been
beating himself up over this and now he
finally has peace. So, he believes that
these beings are not evil, not deceptive
because they read his mind.
Clearly, he he was looking. He didn't
say anything. They read his mind and
telepathically spoke to him and gave him
peace. I finally got peace from that.
Everybody's terrorized by UFOs, orbs,
fire lights.
And I'm thinking about
this relief from what So, I'm in a
different world from them now, right?
I just wanted to show that because
a lot of Christians do not think that
you can receive peace or love or joy
from a demonic entity. That is a lie
from the pit of hell. Ask any new ager,
"What has changed your life?" Remember
this guy said it changed me It changed
me forever. Something's possessing me.
It's with me to this day and it's
guiding me right now.
If you talk to a new ager, they will
tell you, "I got the most peace in my
life when I started meditating. When I
started yoga. When I started visiting
with my ascended masters on a daily
basis. When I started having
communications with
spiritual entities."
These people This isn't demonic. This is
not of God. And yet they are getting the
feeling of love and joy and peace and
people think that Satan cannot
counterfeit that. If you take an ecstasy
pill, you will feel a counterfeit of
love and ecstasy, but it's not of God.
And this is where
Christians are going to be overtaken by
this deception because they think that
Satan can only steal, kill, destroy, and
produce fear, but he is an angel of
light. This is what he didn't do. He did
not test the spirits. First John 4:1-3
says, "Beloved, believe not every
spirit. Do not just believe it because
it's telling you something that makes
you feel good, but try or test the
spirits whether they are of God because
many false prophets are gone into the
world." "Hereby know ye the spirit of
God. Every spirit that confesses that
Jesus Christ has come in the flesh is of
God. And every spirit that confesses not
that Jesus Christ has come in the flesh
is not of God." And this is that spirit
of antichrist. So, if this spirit If he
would have tested the spirit and said,
"Tell me, did Jesus Christ come in the
flesh?"
If this being says, "Well, no, actually,
Jesus is a a form of consciousness. If
you can reach Christ consciousness, he
was a spirit being." If that entity said
anything other than Christ came in the
flesh and died for your sins, then it is
the spirit of antichrist, but he did not
do that. He bought into his emotions,
which the Bible says, "Do not trust your
heart. The heart is deceitful above all
things and desperately wicked. Who can
know it?" Because our emotions are
uncontrollable. They're like an
emotional roller coaster ride. And yet
this guy felt the the sense of peace and
joy and all these things and he is
falling for this. He's surrendering his
will to these demonic entities and he's
a self-professed Christian.
It's a little glowing being about yay
tall with a glowing red eye. When I I
turned back and saw it, it it frightened
me so bad that
my hair stood up. Every cell in my body
went, "Oh my God, I'm dead." I turned
and put my back to the tree and I said,
"I surrender. I'm I don't mean you
harm."
And it said to me in this thunderous
voice. It said, "You don't understand.
We're not here to hurt you. We're here
to help you." And this thing vanishes in
front of me. I can't see it anymore.
Next morning,
when I get up, um
about 10:00 that day, I hadn't had my
medication and I'd been taking
medication for 17 years for Crohn's. And
if I missed it one day, it was it was
supper time. And I didn't feel the
normal sickness that I normally have. I
didn't feel the the nausea. I didn't
feel any of it and I thought, "This is
weird." And from that point forward, I
never had another symptoms of Crohn's
disease. It was completely gone. I've
had specialists check me out from top to
bottom and there there is no marker for
Crohn's being there. Now he's saying
that he was actually healed by these
things. So, not only did he get the the
feeling of peace when these things said
that your dead ex-wife is now in better
in good hands and feelings of joy and
all this stuff, but now he's healed from
a disease that he couldn't get healing
from.
This is another misconception. Can Satan
do healings? Can Satan do miracles? Yes,
if Satan can afflict a person, then he
can remove that affliction and make you
feel like he is a healer.
In the In the book of Job, Satan
afflicted Job with boils from head to
toe.
Satan could have easily removed that
affliction and made Job think that he
was the healer. So, Satan has the power
to do this stuff and yet I don't think
the Christian world believes this. They
think if it's a healing, then it has to
be of God. If you believe that, then you
are going to fall for every new age
teaching. Reiki, uh crystals, and
burning sage. All these things are not
of God and yet people swear that they
work. They say, "I've been healed by
these things. How can it be wrong?"
That's the same logic that the new ager
has who's been deceived by Satan
himself. I told him. I said, "Son, I
said I believe they're angels." He said,
"No, Daddy. They They had to be They had
to
He couldn't even get it out. They They
were They were demonic entities." I
said, "No, they weren't, son. They were
angels.
They healed me."
So, we battled that for
for
months. And here's the thing.
It never left me. I mean, it never left.
And to this day, it's still with me and
I mean stronger today than it was back
then. That is exactly what that
whistleblower saying, right?
It's possessed me and it's with me to
this day.
This is demonic possession 101.
But he says, "I believe that they're
good, holy angels because they healed
me, son."
He hasn't quoted one scripture. He
hasn't tested the spirits. He hasn't
identified the spirit the the angelic
beings according to the Bible. He hasn't
given any kind of scripture at all
except, "They healed me, son."
We cannot buy into our senses. In these
last days, there's going to be deception
on a level that we've never experienced.
We're going to see miracles, signs, and
wonders, and healings, and things that
we've never seen before. We're going to
see a manifestation of Satan
manifesting as Christ.
It's going to be the most amazing,
glorious thing we've ever seen. And
that's why Jesus said, "If they say I'm
in the desert, don't even go. If they
say I'm in the secret chamber, believe
it not." Because who is coming before
Christ? The antichrist, Satan appearing
as Christ. We cannot fall for it no
matter how good it looks, no matter how
good it feels, we cannot fall for the
first coming
of Christ because it's Satan
impersonating Christ.
"And I saw three unclean spirits like
frogs, for they are the spirits of
devils working miracles." So, the Bible
tells us right here that the devils the
spirits of devils can do miracles.
Right here in Matthew 24:24, it says,
"For there shall arise false Christs."
So, not the real Christ, but false
Christ and false prophets and shall show
great signs and wonders in so much that
if it were possible, they shall deceive
the very elect. That word elect is
underlined because I believe that word
is much smaller than we give it credit
for. I think a lot of Christians read
that and say, "Well, I'm I'm a part of
the elect. I believe in the Bible. I
believe in Jesus." No. Jesus said, "The
broad way is to destruction. There's a
narrow way to life and few will there be
that find it." And And he says, "If you
love me, keep my commandments." And he
says all these "Endure until the end. He
who to the end shall be saved. He says
there will be many who will say, "Lord,
Lord, didn't we do all these things in
your name?" And he says, "Depart from
me, I never knew you, you who work
lawlessness."
What Jesus is saying is we need to not
just believe in Jesus, but we need to
obey Jesus. We need to get in his word
and know prophecy. We need to know what
his commandments are. We need to follow
him every step of the way because
Revelation says that those who overcome
this deception are those who follow the
lamb wherever he goes and they know his
voice.
It doesn't just mean I believe and now
that I've been healed by these aliens, I
believe that they are holy angels. That
is a strong delusion right there.
All I wanted to do is tell everybody.
Well, that was the worst thing I did
because now the church comes down on
They know they understand that this is
demonic and he's not listening to his
church. I had the weight of the whole
conference
on me. Not just some little church down
the street. So, there was a lot of power
there.
And other churches to local churches, my
mother, my very religious lady, all at
that time
they all automatically resorted to is
the devil. It's demonic, you know. And
and I'm saying, "But they healed me."
And that that wasn't what I experienced.
That is his only response. They healed
me. It can't be the devil. This is
what's going to trip up so many
Christians in the last days. I mean,
this is what happened at Fatima or
Fatima, however you want to say it.
There was thousands of people, thousands
of Catholics that went to this field.
Three children saw Mary, an apparition
of supposed Mary, and people were
healed. They were hanging up crutches
and stuff. There were thousands of
people that were healed. That was not of
God. That was a demonic deception. Mary
is dead. She's in the grave and she will
not be alive until Christ returns and
the dead in Christ shall rise first.
Anytime you have this type of
experience, we have to test the spirits.
That's something that nobody's doing.
This is why we it's so important that we
understand spiritual warfare and how to
put on the full armor of God, how to
cast out devils. These are all the
things that Jesus said we will be doing
in the last days, that we will do even
greater things than he did, but we got
to be in his word. We got to know how to
discern the the the Christian church has
lost all discernment. We're doing all
the things of the world. We are inviting
the devil in when we are drinking, when
we are smoking marijuana because it's
natural and God made it, when we are
eating unclean things, when we are
watching
all the filth of the world, when we are
putting all the garbage in our ears, the
same thing that all the secular people
are doing, we are giving Satan an
invitation into our lives and that is
giving him a foothold to be able to
deceive us through these lying signs and
wonders. These things can read your
mind. They're connected to our thoughts.
One thing that the church knows is they
always preach. You'll hear it all the
time. Only God can read your thoughts.
Only heaven. Not that the the devil
can't read your thoughts, right? So,
this is something taught to all
Christians from early on. The devil can
whisper in your ear, but he can't read
your mind. Well, these they read your
mind and they know every they're
connected to us. So, that's a very
interesting point that he just made
because I literally just see in the chat
right now somebody saying that angels
good or bad can't read your mind, but I
don't know that there's a single verse
in the Bible that says that. This guy is
saying that they can and we even have
technology today where scientists are
putting nodes on your head and making it
where you can control a computer with
your mind. They can make you think of a
word and they're being able to somehow
see that word on a screen. Like the
technology we have today is getting so
advanced and yet we are not even near as
close as angels are. I'm sure they have
all the all the type of technology to be
able to see infrared and whatever it
takes to be able to either read your
thoughts
or have a very good calculation of what
you're thinking about when you look over
there or whatever is going through your
mind.
They do have the power to to
telepathically
speak to you. This is not anything new.
This is He's not the only person to say
this. So many people have had
demons speak to them telepathically
telling them to kill themselves. You
know, people have having suicidal
thoughts and having uh
thoughts of
killing their neighbor or whatever.
These are not of God and therefore these
are satanic thoughts being implanted
into your mind. When you open the door
for Satan to be in your life, he can
make you have visions of coming out of
your body and flying over the universe.
So many new agers do it willfully. They
are having out of body astral
projection. This is not real. They're
not really leaving their body. They are
having a a vision of coming out of their
body because they're allowing Satan to
have that type of power over them. I can
tell you skeptical people about this
phenomenon will never see anything. They
know your free will. They don't want to,
you know, go against your free will.
They can appear in a group of 50 people,
stand beside me, and that one skeptical
person will look that way for 1 second
and it'll appear in front of everybody
else. If you look into the the mythology
of vampires and things where they can
come to your window, they can come to
your door, but they can't come inside
unless you open the door, right? Unless
you invite them in. That's all just
coming from the truth about demons, the
truth about Satan and his fallen angels.
They cannot have access into your life
unless you give them a door. And like I
said, it can be things that we have
culturally culturally accepted and they
are not of God. And those things are
giving Satan a foothold where he can
come in. Now, he's saying if they don't
believe, they're not going to see it.
But people are going in droves to his
property wanting to see it. They are
going with the mindset, "I want to see
an alien. I want to see what this guy is
talking about." And they will see it
because they are going with that
intention. Have you guys ever heard of
Steven Bancarz? He was a very prominent
new age guru guy who was making
a lot of money. He was living in a
mansion with a sports car. He was raised
Christian and his parents were telling
him, "Look, I don't think this is good
for you to be in this stuff." And he's
saying, "Look at you driving this beat
up car. I'm in a sports car. I'm in a
mansion. I'm making more money than you
guys and I'm like 20." But he had an
encounter with Jesus. He surrendered his
life to Christ. He
went on to his platform, his new age
platform, and took it all back and he
told everybody, "This is a deception.
I've been leading you guys astray.
Please follow Jesus. Please give your
life to Christ." And these people turned
it on him. They said, "You man, you've
become some Jesus freak." They turned on
him and he gave it all up to surrender
everything to Christ. Now, listen to
what he says about angels. Absolutely.
The Bible says that Satan masquerades
himself as an angel of light. That's
really one of his favorite forms to
take. In the New Age movement, for
example,
everyone talks about angels in the New
Age movement by name.
Really?
Raphael, um Archangel Michael, and they
believe they're making contact with
these angels.
Wait a minute. In the New Age movement,
you're saying that it's very customary
for them to talk about angels in the
Bible and and the names of the angels in
the Bible.
Beyond customary. It's it's a staple
practice and doctrine. Yeah, absolutely.
In fact, my the one who wrote the
endorsement for the for the back of the
book, her name is Doreen Virtue. She was
a best-selling author for Hay House
Publishers. They're all-time
best-selling author.
Right. And her whole career was about
contacting the angels. She was a medium.
She would contact them. They'd bring
through messages
to her clients to to, you know, either
give them wisdom or some kind of
prophecy about their lives. So, this has
been a favorite
shapeshift of demons Right. for a very
long time. And what I've been seeing and
discerning in in the hyper-charismatic
circles, if you will, is that people are
more interested in in angelic encounter
Right. than they are with being a
disciple of Jesus. People tell me
they're like, "Man, I saw Gabriel last
night and he was massive." And I know a
guy who said like, "I have I saw my
spirit man and he's huge. And when he
walks, he's got speakers on his feet and
it just shakes the earth." And I'm like,
"Dude, I don't know if this is
real. I don't know if this is of God."
These are demonic deceptions that people
are having these encounters with angels.
These new age people, they talk to their
spirit guides. They talk to the ascended
masters. And they will tell you, "I
talked to Jesus." You as a Christian,
you can talk to a new ager and they're
not even uncomfortable. They're like,
"Oh, yeah, I know Jesus. I talk to him
every day. I see him. Actually, I have
conversations with Gabriel and Michael
and all those guys." When you read New
Age literature, it literally has Bible
verses all through it because they're
telling you you can reach Christ
consciousness, that Jesus when he
ascended back to heaven, when he after
he was crucified, he just reached Chris
Christ consciousness. He evolved and and
reached that state of being that we can
all reach if we just tap into it, if we
open up our third eye and all this
stuff. If you believe it, you shall
receive it and all these things. They
take these scriptures and they get rid
of Christ altogether and they say, "No,
it's Christ within. That's what the
Bible's really saying is that we are
Christ, that we are all collectively
Christ. And if we speak it, we can speak
it into existence just like he did
because if we are made in his image,
then we are like little gods. And if we
speak it, it'll happen, That the
universe will open up and everything
will just come to us because we spoke it
into existence. That is a lie from the
pit of hell. Now, he mentioned
Doreen Virtue. She is a
a now a Christian. She has her own
Christian YouTube channel and she
denounces all the new age stuff that she
used to be in. This video was from 2011.
It's still up on Spirit TV because she
was so well-renowned in that new age
world. She was a best-selling author in
the new age world. And um you see right
here she's talking about guardian angels
are all around. Hi, I'm Doreen Virtue
and you may know of me from my books
about angels and my oracle cards that
help you to get in touch with the
angels. And I also give seminars around
the world to help you to get messages
from your guardian angels and the
archangels as well as get in touch with
your departed loved ones. This is why
it's so important to understand what
happens when you die because I was
raised my whole Christian life until I
was in my 20s, I guess,
to believe that when you die you're not
actually dead. That everyone
innately has some immortal ghost living
inside them and when you die, that ghost
is going to exit and it's going to go on
living somewhere. That is
opening up a door for you to believe
that you can talk to your dead loved
ones. And I've even heard Christians
say, "Oh yes, my mother came to visit me
last night and she told me that how
great heaven is and all these things."
And this is what we're going to start
seeing more and more of in these last
days. Spiritualism in the last days.
This whole alien thing is nothing more
than spiritualism in a new disguise. Not
even really a new disguise. The ancient
Egyptians worshipped beings from the
stars. The Babylonians worshipped the
Anunnaki, beings from the stars. This is
the same thing. Satan in a new disguise
is the serpent in the garden, the
Anunnaki, and now we have the gray
aliens and the the blonds that wear blue
jumpsuits.
It's Satan just masquerading over and
over, but this is the final masquerade.
This is the one that's going to deceive
the entire world because the dragon is
going to deceive the whole world, it
says. It doesn't matter if you're an
atheist, it doesn't matter if you're a
Muslim or Buddhist or any of those
things. When you see this with your own
eyes and there's a supernatural being
who caused peace on earth because when
they say peace and safety, sudden
destruction will come upon them. It's
going to be a false peace.
It's going to be false religion. It's
going to be a coexist movement that
says, "It doesn't matter if you're
Buddhist or Muslim or Jewish or Hindu.
We all serve the same God. It's love."
And that's what God is. It's a new age
philosophy. It's going to be a one world
religion and it's going to be enforced
by law one day. If you don't worship
like this,
you will be beheaded. And if you do
worship like this, you will be taking
the mark of the beast. If you believe in
it, you're taking it in your forehead.
If you don't believe in it, but you obey
it, you're taking it in the hand. You
can take the mark of the spiritual mark
of the beast in two forms, whether you
believe it or whether you're just
obeying it. She's not a Christian at
this point and she's talking about
angels and guardian angels and by name
and how they're all around us and how
they don't want to interfere with our
free will, just like Chris Bledsoe said.
You have free will. I have free will.
And while your angels might stand by
praying, "Gosh, I wish that they'd ask
for my help today."
They can't force it on you.
But they're there. I mean, this is how
deceptive this is.
The whole fact that they're calling
these things angels and believing in the
healings and the signs and wonders is
exactly what the Bible says is going to
happen in the last days and millions are
going to fall for it.
Took me to the hospital.
Next day I know
I'm up in the space looking down
from from way up high. I can see the
earth getting smaller and smaller and
smaller.
And then I wake up and I'm in I'm out of
surgery and I'm in an X-ray room. All I
remember is is seeing earth from above
and being out of my body in total peace.
Um I wasn't cold. I wasn't afraid. I was
just had a marvel of looking at all
this. And then when I came back to,
there's my mom looking through the
window crying.
So, what he's talking about is he had
two near-death experiences. One when he
was a child about 10 years old, he was
shot in the shoulder with some buckshot
at a close range by his friend. It was a
It was a freak accident. And he had
out-of-body experience, but he's talking
about how
he was in the hospital. He was doped up
with drugs because when you look at the
word pharmaceuticals,
it's the word sorcery. When you look in
the Bible in Revelation when it says
that the world was deceived by sorcery,
that is the Greek word pharmakeia. And
so, when people have this same
experience he had, the I shot up out of
the were out of the universe into the
space, that is the same experience that
a new ager has when they astral project,
when somebody's going into another
country to take ayahuasca because they
want to have some kind of peace in their
life and find the truth or when somebody
does DMT. It's the same story. I shot
out of my body into outer space. I felt
God and she was beautiful. It's always
this divine feminine or I was in outer
space. I was out of my body. The Bible
never talks about this stuff. It never
once documents that when Lazarus came
back to life, he said, "Man, let me tell
you about heaven." Or when the uh
centurion's daughter came back to life,
it never documents that when somebody
came back from the dead, they talk about
shooting up out of the universe and what
they saw. Never. Not once. We have to
test everything according to the word of
God. This is a deception. He was doped
up on pharmaceutical sorcery, which
opens up the door for Satan to come into
your life and to give you a deception
like this, an astral projection
deception. And I just come out of the
hospital, too, and I was heavily
medicated.
But I knew that opened me up
to the spiritual world, to the to the
other side.
So, I think when he says, "I know that
opened me up to the spirit world." I
think he's talking about the near-death
experience.
But why would why did he have this
out-of-body experience? Because he was
doped up. He literally just said in the
clip,
"I was heavily medicated." Of course,
when you're in the hospital after a
gunshot wound, you're going to be
heavily medicated and that's when you
fly out of your body and have this
crazy astral projection experience and
he says, "That moment from that moment,
that opened him up to the divine world."
I'm not surprised. This is where this
all began. This is why he is
chosen to be to have entities like this
coming in his life, deceiving him
because every time he has this
encounter, instead of testing the
spirits, instead of casting them out in
the name of Jesus, he's accepting them.
He's surrendering to them. He's
embracing them. He's saying they healed
me. He's defending them. This is of
course, it's in him and not going away
like he said. "It's in me right now and
it's not going anywhere and it's
stronger than ever before." Because he's
literally defending demons in his life.
So, with the being, how would it
converse back with you? I could hear it
audible speaking, but it didn't move its
mouth. It's like you could hear it.
Was it English? Yeah.
Very deep voice. Very loud.
But now today it's more telepathic. It's
It's It's images. It's And we've proven
that that on television, on the History
Channel, that's my brain is
communicating with this phenomena. Wow,
the History Channel?
You mean the one that propagates ancient
aliens that says that Moses was led out
of the wilderness by a beam from a UFO
and Ezekiel was seeing a UFO when he saw
a wheel within a wheel and chariots of
fire and all this stuff? The same
company that promotes all this stuff did
an interview with him and proved by
putting all these things on his head
that he was connecting with something.
Yeah, he is.
He really is. He's connecting with
demons that are attached to his life
because he keeps defending them and
saying that they are good angels that
have healed him and he has nothing
substantial to back it up at all except
that they make him feel good. That's all
he has.
And he's never once tested these
spirits. He actually thinks that the
church who's coming against these things
and saying that they're demonic, well,
they must be closed-minded. They just
think everything's the devil because
they don't understand. They didn't have
the experience that I had.
Mhm. We got to pray for this guy. Chris
Bledsoe, put him on your prayer list
because what a amazing evangelist he
could be for the truth if he understood
the truth. Right now, he's literally an
evangelist for Satan.
He's literally telling everyone embrace
these beings because they can heal you
and and solve all the problems in life.
Red eyes and it had a triangle
shape underneath it. It was glowing,
gleaming from head to toe. They had this
triangle on its chest.
Right here. And that turned out to be a
pretty big symbol for some people in the
government.
What What is that symbol?
Well, there's one right here from NASA.
They had a triangle on their chest? I I
think he's talking about the vector. The
vector that NASA uses and actually every
space agency uses this same Star Trek
logo thing, this triangular shape
that was on the chest of the holy angel
that is now a really prominent symbol in
the government, he said, including NASA.
You mean the the organization whose name
means deceive in Hebrew?
Who's propagating all this
space travel and things that you can
prove are fake when you look up uh
bubbles in space or green screen
glitches and harness wires and all these
things that these
supposed space agencies are doing when
they hairspray their hair straight up
and say that they're in space.
This is another deception. Literally
NASA to deceive.
And that's where the triangle came from?
This is all the more evidence not to
believe these beings.
But you know the he says he's the most
studied person by the government. He
said that they actually put things on
his head and that he um
telepathically was communicating with
some being that was telling him that the
Pope was going to be attacked. He wrote
about it in his book and he said that he
was able to tell the military exactly
who was going to attack the Pope and
they found the young man and took him
down and prevented the Pope from dying.
Like this is the type of stuff that of
course Satan can tell you that. Of
Dude, Satan has agents all over. He's
got unholy angels watching everything,
documenting everything. He can tell you
who's about to attack the Pope.
And then now he looks like a hero. This
is the Hegelian dialect. He's playing
both sides, good cop, bad cop. He has to
create chaos in order to create order.
He has to
make you believe that he is good by
revealing his wicked plan
and and helping you to stop it.
It's it's
it's too much to even comprehend, but
when you know what to look for, when
those blinders get knocked off your eyes
like God did for me in December 2011,
you can't unsee this stuff. All of a
sudden everything has these red flags
and you're starting to connect the dots
and you can see the big picture, but
there is a world of people out there
that have no clue what's coming. Imagine
somebody who's never even read the
Bible. All they know is like my grandma
used to go to church, I don't know. They
have no clue what's coming.
They are
completely set up for this.
All they're going to know is there's a
supernatural being I can't deny. It
healed me of everything. It stopped It
made world peace. Why would I not bow
down and worship this being?
We have to use every platform we have to
get this message out. We have to get in
the churches and speak about this topic.
I It bothers me so much that the church
is not talking about this topic. I thank
God that he's opened up the doors for me
to share this UFO deception in many
churches, but we need to be talking
about it more. If you guys would like to
invite Can of Truth to come to your
church and talk about the alien topic,
please go to canoftruth.org. You can
click booking.
We will come to your church no matter
where it's at and we will give this
presentation. If you don't want to do
it, I'll give you your my presentation
for free. You can have my presentation
if you will share it with the church. If
not, if you feel uncomfortable, invite
us and share this channel, share Strange
Normal. We are out here trying to get
the message out there. We are exposing
the deceptions of the enemy so that we
will not be deceived in these last days.
There's a description in Daniel gave
chapter 10
in the Bible where he describes an
angelic being that he's encounter and he
says it it was his body was gleaming
like topaz and it had
torches fire red glowing eyes.
This is Daniel's description straight
out of the Bible.
Did it say it was two two foot tall? Oh
my goodness, this is crazy. It
immediately followed me home and
it these orbs would appear, ball of
light flash
and out steps these shadowy figures and
they would walk through the house and
walk through walls. They look like a
human, same size and all. So these
things are walking through walls,
they're shadowy figures, but none of
this is uh alarming him at all.
How What about this being made you think
that it was a guardian angel and that it
had your best best interest? Well, it
was talking to me. It was there. It told
me it was there to protect me. It was
watching over me
and that I was going to be fine. Because
they they told me they're here to
protect me. All they have to do is tell
you? This dude is not even questioning
anything. He Not only is he not testing
the spirits according to what the
scripture says, but if they say they're
here to protect him, he doesn't even
question it. I mean if a if a
bus or a van with no windows pulled up
next to him and a dude in a trench coat
popped out and said, "Hey, I got some
candy for you. Come in the van." Would
he go in the van? I mean this dude has
zero discernment. I don't I I don't
understand why people are not
more hesitant to trust
spiritual entities. Do we not realize
that there is not just good angels, but
there's also bad angels? A third of the
angels are wicked.
This is oh man.
We have to use discernment. Like we have
to be testing the spirits. We This guy
needs to know the truth. I don't know
how to reach him. I know that he's heard
from his church.
His His family's tried to tell him the
truth, but now he's he's convinced his
family now that these beings are are
good.
And that's when he healed me and he
said, "We're not here to hurt you, we're
here to help you."
Did you respond to that? Yeah. What did
you say?
Well, I didn't really speak other than I
surrender. I I'm I'm sorry. I don't mean
you any harm and it's telling me this in
my head
and I felt this greatest joy and this
sense of relief that I understood now
um no more fear.
And that's why I immediately when I
reported it I knew it was these same
angelic beings, but it didn't look like
this little being I'd seen 2 years
prior. He He repeatedly talks about
surrendering to these beings.
And because they make him feel joy
and peace
and healing,
that's all the evidence he needs to
believe that these are holy angels.
Like
now
because
his whole mission is to share this.
That's what he says. Maybe he needs to
Maybe he says that in the next clip.
But he says, "All I want to do is share
this."
He is evangelizing
that demonic beings are holy angels.
And it it's only going to get more and
more. I mean we already see the military
saying,
"Yeah, there's things flying around the
sky, but don't worry. There It's not our
technology. It's not their technology.
We don't know what it is, but don't
worry. They're nice. They're They're not
a threat."
So they're getting us used to the idea
of spiritual beings
manifesting in the skies and just go
about with life. It's okay. Don't worry
about it.
And now they're being told by the
church, "Your dad is is dealing with
demons." Well,
it it
they didn't want to believe it because
they were seeing it with me. So it was
it was a horrible place to be
when the whole community come down on us
there.
So now his family is seeing this stuff,
too.
His son is actually on the set here and
and the guy asked him at the the host,
he was like, "How'd you feel about your
dad talking to that being or whatever?"
And he said, "We just thought he was,
you know, high on the the medication. We
were laughing or whatever, but
I'm I'm pretty sure
that he has his family convinced that
these things are are friendly.
And so now if they are also
surrendering to them and embracing them,
then
they're in the deception as well.
He's the He's the spiritual household
leader.
And he's got his his household
convinced. But not just his household.
He actually has people by the droves
coming to his house to experience this
phenomenon. She said, "If you will tell
this story, I'll always be with you.
I'll allow you to share our presence
with others and film us.
So help me.
I never had a picture of anything for
the previous 5 years. Only inside the
house would people see this or or out in
my my children.
Now everybody's
coming to the house and it appears
overhead. It appears around us
and it's greater today than it was then.
So now everybody sees it and it's
bigger and greater. It's doing greater
things now than it ever did. Uh is a
bull on the side of the wall in the
king's chamber. You only can see it with
this technology has and the stars are
inside. And above it is a helix, a DNA.
And then on the sarcophagus
in the king's chamber is the alpha and
omega symbol.
And what do you think that represents?
It repre Well, alpha and omega is God,
the beginning and the end. The bull
is the uh is the celestial bull, The uh
To me is To me, the lady
that came
to me is the Holy Spirit.
Oh my goodness.
The lady that came to me is the Holy
Spirit.
Wow. And isn't this lining up with the
first guy, the whistleblower, who picked
up the 20-ft egg?
So, both of them saw a white egg. Both
of them feel possessed and this being is
with them to this day. Both of them say
it's a woman. That other guy said that I
felt
the
It was the greatest possession I've ever
been possessed by and it was this
woman. It was a divine It was a feminine
god.
And it was a god, but not in the
masculine sense.
So, divine feminine
overwhelming love, joy, and peace
the tears, emotions white egg
craft
and uh
this guy is
you know, opening up his home for
everybody to see this. Every I want
everyone to experience this.
So, now he's not talking about Jesus
anymore. He's not like
give your life to Jesus. He's not
preaching the gospel.
He's preaching come see these angelic
beings.
This is
a recipe for disaster.
Do you think there's any significance to
this happening on Easter? 100%. And what
is that?
Well, you tell me what Easter means and
uh It's the resurrection. Yeah.
Every year, every year at Easter
either she comes back or some something
miraculous happens.
Every year at Easter.
So, why is that significant?
Like, they're associating Easter with
Jesus.
Easter has nothing to do with Jesus.
Easter is a fertility pagan ritual.
And it it's based around Ishtar.
And so, it's kind of ironic that there's
this
female angel Holy Spirit that he's
talking about. He's saying that I think
this woman that's presenting herself to
me is the Holy Spirit.
This woman, Ishtar, is appearing every
Easter
at his house.
Crazy.
She's always comes in threes.
Not always, but it's it's overwhelming.
Three is very meaningful in this. Three.
And I thumbed it over and over. Three
orbs, you know, together. They'll line
up like a triangle. They'll plot through
the sky in a triangle. I said, "Uh well,
if I didn't, I'll give you a video of
that."
So, remember that he said three. He's
going to say it again later that these
entities always show up in threes.
Dozens of people every day.
It's every day. I can show you.
And now it's I don't I just pray for
them or
I just You know, you if you know
somebody that's sick, they might send me
a photo now. And
I just take the photo out and I hold it
up to the heavens and I ask uh
the angels, God.
I never pray to angel. I pray to God.
And I ask for this help for this person
and
I get these letters back.
He said I I take the picture and I hold
it up to the heavens and
pray to the angels or God. I don't pray
to angels. I pray to God.
But, he's obsessed with these angels.
These angels
healed him and so, he believes they can
heal these people, too. And he says, "I
get letters all the time from people."
He even heals dogs and everything. So,
this is just like Fatima.
The three kids that saw this
apparition of Mary and people were being
healed. Thousands of people would come
there every year on the 13th. I think it
was October 13th. It was not
Yeah, every year or every month on the
13th, which isn't a cult number. I think
that's weird, too. How come it these
beings always show up on some pagan or
pagan holiday or an occult number?
Very interesting.
Tell us the phenomenon with me, the
experience with it. This is why I know
it's from the divine world. It's not
something with teeth and a ray gun
coming here to get us.
It's connected to our thoughts. It'll
appear a lot when I ask it and in front
of me and you and others. Not every
time, but pretty much pretty much all
the time. Uh sometimes 50, 70 orbs will
appear. Sometimes it's a little fire
that'll appear right beside me like a
candle. I've seen it.
I look over and oh my god, it's right
there. And then it'll shoot off over my
head. And a lot of people have seen
this. Rock stars. Uh very big rock stars
uh without saying their names have been
in my house
um
and have witnessed this up close and
personal.
Senior service members of the DIA
SEAL Team Six teens in in my house with
their families and have experienced it.
So, yeah, that's that's real credible.
We got rock rock stars. They see them,
too.
Yeah, rock stars are messing around with
the occult. They're literally
blaspheming Christ in their music and
everything. Of course, they're going to
see the stuff. People in the military
no offense to anybody who may be in the
military, but
all of this is a satanic system.
War is a satanic system. Pharmaceutical,
big pharma, satanic system. So, it's no
shock that these people are are getting
to experience this
phenomenon. But, anyone who goes there
willfully wanting and desiring to see
these things will see them because that
desire is the door that they need.
And and this guy is is
soften is is bringing down any walls
that may be there because well, he's a
Christian.
This guy loves Jesus. He said his his
faith in Jesus is stronger now than ever
before.
I was inside a bubble.
Top thing that was solid that I could
stand on, but I couldn't see the walls,
but I could touch them.
But, I could see everything in every
direction.
And there were always three
figures behind me
that were shadowy and they were
narrating what I was seeing.
Now, okay. So, like I said earlier, he
said that these things always appear in
three. Now, there's three shadowy
figures that are with him. What does the
Bible say?
I saw three unclean spirits like frogs.
For they are the spirits of devils
working miracles.
Miracles. They healed him.
Which go forth into the kings of the
earth and the whole world to gather them
to the battle of the great day of God
Almighty. These are unclean spirits that
are working miracles. If this guy read
the Bible, he could see the truth and
the truth would make him free.
Oh, Lord, please open the eyes of Chris
Bledsoe.
Let him be a true evangelist for you.
Let him be an evangelist that exposes
this satanic lie just like me who was
deceived by the occult and all these
things.
I'm using whatever platform I can to
expose the enemy's lies. Let this guy
who's got a huge platform already
open his eyes, Lord.
Give him eyes to see that he will use
his platform to expose Satan's deception
in these last days.
What's going to happen, I don't know.
But, I think it's possible that's the
that's uh
the return of
Christ. Yeah.
Or the lady and the whole heavenly host
living with us, Jesus.
That's the first time I've ever said
that in my life publicly.
So, I have to give you a little
backstory on that because I didn't catch
the first part of the clip.
He said that this lady keeps talking
about Easter of 2026.
Next year.
Like, just barely over a year from now.
That something major and significant's
going to happen. And he says, "I think
it's going to be the the return of
Christ."
He said, "I No man knows, but he said,
"We do know that if Now, this is what he
believes. It's actually going to be in
the next uh thing. Check this out.
You are the only one
to my knowledge
that I've spoken to on this subject, on
the UFO subject, that believes in Jesus
Christ.
I do wholeheartedly. More today than I
ever did.
So,
now that he's had these encounters, he
believes in Jesus more than ever before.
That's
that's wild. You know, and and some
people believe
if somebody's talking about Jesus, they
can't be possessed by demons. This guy
says that these beings are possessing
him and guiding him.
Um so, there is a a misconception in the
Christian world that as long as you
believe in Jesus and talk about Jesus,
there's no way you can be possessed.
There's no way you could be being used
by the enemy.
But, check out what scripture says.
In 2 Thessalonians 2:3, it says, "Let no
man deceive you by any means, for that
day shall not come except there come a
falling away first. And that man of sin
shall be revealed, the son of perdition.
So, we know that in the last days
there's going to be strong delusion,
deception. We know there's going to be a
falling away first before Christ
returns.
We know in Revelation 12:9 and 12:9 it
says, "And the dragon was cast out, that
old serpent called the devil and Satan,
which deceives the whole world. He was
cast to the earth and his angels were
cast out with him."
Satan is here on earth.
That's the angels that are right here on
earth that are deceiving the whole
world.
I believe 100%
these   angels that he's
seeing
are Satan and his angels.
1 Timothy 4:1 and 2 says, "Now the
Spirit expressly says that in the latter
time some will depart from the faith."
You cannot depart from something you
never had a part of.
There's a misconception about once
saved, always saved. I said a little
prayer when I was 10, I'll always be a
Christian. It's not true. There's so
many things in the Bible. The prodigal
son is a prime example of someone who
was with the father, chose to turn and
leave the father, and the father was
standing there arms wide open waiting
for his prodigal son to return. When
that prodigal son returned, he said, "My
son was dead, but now he's alive. My son
um
was I can't remember what it is dead and
now he's alive. My son was lost and now
he is found." Dead and lost mean you're
not saved. But once he returned, the
father ran to him, put a ring on his
finger, hugged him and kissed him, put a
robe on him.
That is a prime example of that you can
choose to turn from your faith. And in
these last days there's going to be
many people that will depart from the
faith. Well, some it says, "Some will
depart from the faith giving heed to
what? Deceiving spirits."
Exactly what this guy is seeing. And
doctrines of demons speaking lies and
hypocrisies having their own conscience
seared with a hot iron. Our conscience
is how the Holy Spirit talks to us.
God's law is written on our hearts.
That's why we innately know that murder
is wrong, that stealing is wrong because
we have a conscience.
And when you are giving heed to these
seducing spirits,
you are departing from the faith and
that conscience is seared. That's why
this guy does not have
a discernment anymore.
That all he can do is say, "Well,
they're telling me they're guarding me.
They're telling they're healing me."
Matthew 24:26
through "Wherefore, if they shall say
unto you, behold, he's in the desert, go
not forth. Behold, he's in the secret
chambers, believe it not. For as
lightning cometh out of the east and
shining even unto the west, so shall
also the sun coming in the son of man
be."
Christ is telling us, "Do not fall for
these
false Christs."
We know that it's a false Christ that's
going to come before the true Christ.
We're not sitting here waiting for
Christ to come and set up a a perfect
kingdom on earth. That is
misunderstood prophecy.
Satan is going to appear as a cosmic
Christ first and deceive millions of
people. And Jesus is saying, "If they
say he's here on earth somewhere, don't
even go. You will fall for the
deception."
Now,
to back up the fact that this guy can be
a a self-professed Christian, he can
talk about Jesus all day long, just like
New Agers do, and still be used by
Satan.
Acts 16:16 through 18 says, "A certain
damsel possessed with a spirit of
divination met us and cried saying,
'These men are the servants of the most
high God, which show us un show unto us
the way of salvation.'" This lady was
speaking the truth.
She was saying that Paul and these other
guys were leading you unto salvation,
that they serve the most high God. But
she was possessed.
"And this did she many days, but Paul
being grieved turned and said to the
spirit, 'I command thee in the name of
Jesus Christ to come out of her.' And he
came out in that same hour."
This woman
was saying what sounded like the truth,
but she was possessed by a demon and
Paul cast it out of her.
So, 2 Corinthians 11:13 through
"For such are false apostles, deceitful
workers,
transforming themselves into the
apostles of Christ."
So, Satan can manifest as apostles of
Christ. Think about people in these mega
churches. Think about what Kenneth
Copeland looks like. He might literally
be
a deceitful spirit transformed into an
apostle of Christ. "And no marvel, for
Satan himself is transformed into an
angel of light."
If Satan can masquerade as a beautiful
angel of light that'll deceive millions
of people,
his fallen angels have the same kind of
power. Therefore, it is no great thing
if his ministers also be transformed as
the ministers of righteousness. Satan's
fallen angels can transform themselves
into ministers of righteousness.
"But though we or an angel from heaven"
This is scripture, Galatians 1:8.
"Though we or an angel from heaven
preach any other gospel unto you
than what we have preached unto you, let
him be accursed. Let that angel be
accursed." If they are telling you
anything contrary to the word of God,
and yet Chris Bledsoe is not even
testing the spirits. He's not even
asking, "Did Christ come in the flesh?"
Like the Bible tells us to test.
And in the book of Revelations, in the
very last chapter
it says,
when the armies surround Israel on all
four sides,
that he's coming back to fight the
battle
and rid the world of evil.
And then there'll be a time of peace,
1,000 years.
So, this is why it is so important to
understand prophecy.
You know, Paul said,
um "Though I speak with many tongues and
I I wish you guys spoke with tongues, I
wish more that you understood prophecy.
I wish you had the gift of prophecy."
The Bible has
all the prophecies laid out, but if we
are not in God's word, we can't
understand it. And that's what Satan's
banking on.
Satan's banking that you will not study
the word of God yourself. That we live
in America, every home has a Bible on
the shelf somewhere, but we're not
reading it. There's other countries
where people are being killed for having
a Bible and they're in a basement by
candlelight dying to just have a Bible
study, and we have Bibles in our homes
and don't even read them. We got Bible
apps on our phone and don't even read
them.
That's what Satan's banking on because
if you're going to church once a week
and just hearing what the pastor says
and he's saying, "Oh, you're beautiful
and lovely and God wants you to be rich
and just say this affirmation and
believe and you shall receive," then you
will not
stand a chance when this last deception
comes. If you don't understand that
Christ is returning
uh like lightning from the east to the
west, that he's not stepping foot on the
earth
until after the 1,000 years is finished,
then you will fall for this
masquerade. You will fall for this
cosmic Christ that comes and is doing
lying signs and wonders.
If you don't understand the timing of
the millennium and all these types of
things, you are setting yourself up to
fall for Satan posing as Christ.
So, I want to go through some of the
scriptures because
every church I know of, every
every denomination out there, all
believe that Christ is going to
set up his perfect kingdom of peace
right here on earth for 1,000 years and
then Satan is going to be loosed to
deceive a number like the sand of the
sea.
That doesn't even make sense. If you are
enduring to the end, you're picking up
your cross daily and you're walking that
narrow path that only few will find,
and you either die or um get,
you know, caught up to meet the Lord in
the air when he returns,
then wow, it's amazing that we made it
because it's a narrow path.
Then 1,000 years of peace on earth with
Jesus,
and Satan's going to be loosed and
deceive a number like the sand of the
sea.
See, these people they can't under they
can't
explain that to you. They actually think
it's a big mystery. Like, why is why is
God going to do that? Some people will
say, "Well, during the millennium people
will be having babies and it's these new
people that are being born that they'll
actually be deceived because a a new
kind of seed of doubt enters into the
world again." But Jesus said when they
asked him, "This woman was married to
this man, he died, she married his
brother, he died, and on and on and on."
He married she married like seven
brothers. "Who's wife will she be in the
kingdom?"
And he said, "You don't understand the
scriptures.
That after the resurrection, we will not
give into marriage, but we will become
like the angels."
Jesus said there will not be marriage
and therefore there will not be sex and
therefore there will not be procreation
in the new kingdom after the
resurrection.
So, that's gone out. You can't you can't
use that excuse. So, why would Satan be
able to deceive a number like the sand
of the sea of
a bunch of Christians who have been
living on in perfect peace with Christ
for 1,000 years?
Because this is what the scriptures
really say about what happens.
When he comes,
it says, then we which are alive and
remain, us believers who are alive,
shall be caught up together in the cloud
together with them in the clouds to meet
the Lord in the air. The dead in Christ
and the living in Christ are caught up
to meet the Lord in the air,
and so shall we ever be with the Lord.
So, where are the Christians at this
point? When Christ returns, where are
the Christians? They're up.
They're up in the air with the Lord.
Where are the wicked?
It says, and then shall that wicked one
that wicked be revealed, whom the Lord
shall consume with the spirit of his
mouth and shall destroy with the
brightness of his coming.
So, when Christ returns, the righteous
are caught up, the wicked are consumed
and destroyed by the brightness of his
coming. So, who's left on Earth?
No one. No human is left on Earth.
Only Satan and his fallen angels are
still here on Earth.
On a desolate, destroyed Earth.
Revelation 20:1-2 says, and I saw an
angel come down from heaven having the
key to the bottomless pit. That word
bottomless pit is a a poor translation.
It's from the Greek word abussos, which
means abyss or empty void. Because he's
still here on Earth on a desolate Earth.
And a great chain in his hand, and he
laid hold on the dragon, that old
serpent, which is the devil and Satan,
and bound him for a thousand years. So,
the righteous are caught up, the wicked
are slain,
Satan is bound on this Earth, a desolate
abyss.
Revelation 20:5 says, but the rest of
the dead, who who is this talking about?
Because the righteous are alive. We're
in heaven.
The rest of the dead are the wicked. The
rest of the dead, those wicked, live not
again until the thousand years were
finished. I don't hear any church talk
about who are the rest of the dead. Who
who are the rest of the dead that come
back to life after the thousand years?
If we are alive on Earth with Jesus for
a thousand years, who are these people?
That makes no sense in the understanding
that
Jesus is setting up a perfect kingdom on
Earth for a thousand year millennial.
The millennial reign is what they say.
What's really going on is we are in
heaven with Christ for a thousand years,
and the Bible says that the books are
open.
We get to see every secret sin. We get
to see every time that someone rejected
Christ because when we get there's going
to be three surprises. Everybody talks
about this. One is that you're there.
Like, I'm surprised I made it. The next
one is
why is that person not here? Why is
Pastor Joe not here?
Then the third surprise is why is he
here?
That dude was terrible.
But God knows the intentions of the
heart. God knew every secret thing,
whether that person gave their life to
Christ on their deathbed, whether your
dear old grandma rejected Christ,
whatever it was, we're going to get to
see it. For a thousand years, we get to
go through all the records because it
says judgment is given unto us.
We get to be the judges.
Paul said, do you not know that you will
judge angels?
So, after the thousand years of being in
heaven with Christ, we are going to
return with Christ, and we are backing
him up. We are his jury. He's the judge,
we are the jury. We're in 100%
agreement. If there was even one iota of
doubt in our mind that Christ's judgment
was not just,
we will see their true colors because
after they are resurrected, after the
wicked are resurrected, it says that
they went up on the breadth of the Earth
and they compassed the city of the
saints. They're trying to take over the
New Jerusalem by force because Satan now
has a short season to deceive them.
Remember, Satan's on a desolate Earth.
The wicked are resurrected and now in
this moment he can say, I just
resurrected you. I'm your God. Look at
this evil alien invader trying to take
over our Earth. We got to fight.
And we got to take that city over by
force. They go up on the the breadth of
the Earth. They compassed the city of
the saints, and in that moment we will
see their true colors.
None of those people are worthy of
eternal life in the kingdom. They are
all wicked. And Jesus brings fire from
God out of heaven and devours them, and
it's such a painful sight to see that it
says he wipes away all our tears.
There'll be no more tears, no more
sorrow. He sets up a new, perfect Earth,
and at that moment,
after the thousand years is finished,
after the destruction of the wicked,
that's when Christ makes the Earth new.
And we live in a perfect world on Earth
forever, for eternity. No more pain, no
more sorrow.
If you're still skeptical about what I'm
saying, like, I don't know that the
Bible ever talks about a desolate Earth
where Satan is bound or any of this
stuff, look at Jeremiah.
Jeremiah 4:23-26 says, and I beheld the
Earth, and lo, it was without form. That
sounds like Genesis, right?
And void. So, the Earth is
an abyss. It's void.
And the heavens, they had no light. I
beheld the mountains, and lo, they
trembled. And the hills, they moved
lightly. I beheld and there was no man.
Because the wicked were consumed and the
righteous were caught up to meet the
Lord in the air.
And the birds of the heavens were fled.
I beheld and lo, the fruitful place was
a wilderness, and all the cities thereof
were broken down at the presence of the
Lord and by his fierce anger. This is
describing when Christ returns.
And
he's destroyed the wicked. Everything is
a void, but Satan is bound to this
place, this desolate Earth, for a
thousand years
until the thousand years is finished.
And that's when it says Satan is loosed
for a short season.
Who's he deceiving?
The wicked who are now resurrected for
their judgment.
Ephesians 6:12 says, we do not wrestle
against flesh and blood, but against
principalities, against powers, against
the rulers of the darkness of this age,
against spiritual hosts of wickedness in
heavenly places. The Bible's literally
telling us that evil spirits are flying
around in the heavenly places. This is
what Chris Bledsoe is seeing.
This is what he's having encounters
with.
But he's
all he can say is, well, they healed me.
They must be safe. No. We cannot fall
for the lying signs and wonders from
these demon
miracle working demons.
That's what the Bible says.
Remember
that even the magicians were able to
imitate some of the miracles of God.
Um uh the staffs became snakes,
the water turning to blood, being able
to call up the frogs out of the water.
The Egyptian magicians were able to
imitate these things.
And
we know that Satan has the power to do
miraculous things. In the book of Job,
he caused fireballs to come down from
heaven and kill Job's family and destroy
all his property, all his uh cattle.
He was able to afflict Job from head to
toe with boils.
So, Satan has great power. Another
deception is that Christians think
oh, Satan, he's just this puny thing. He
ain't nothing. He ain't nothing on me.
He deceived Eve, a perfect being in a
perfect garden.
If he can deceive Eve, we are no match
for him. I mean, we are so
out of touch,
our our relationship with God is so
distant in these last days,
that if we are not in God's word every
single day,
if we are not in prayer every moment of
every day, pray without ceasing, then we
are in danger of falling for this great,
mammoth deception.
I pray this was eye-opening to you.
Please share it with your family and
friends because there is a great
deception coming that's going to fool
millions of Christians with this
emotional love and joy and healings and
all these things, but Satan is the one
that comes first. Satan masquerading as
Christ, and then
Christ comes, and we will be caught up
to meet the Lord in the air. He's not
going to be on the ground. He's not
going to be in the secret chambers. He's
not going to be in the desert. I love
you guys. I thank you guys. If you want
to support this ministry, you can do so
by going to candidtruth.org.
We got a donate button. You can also do
it through Cash App, Venmo, Zelle, or
PayPal.
We need you. We cannot do this without
you guys. We stepped out in faith to
continue doing this um online ministry,
and God has been providing each month
because of faithful donors like you. We
love you guys. We can't do this without
you. If you like t-shirts, we have some
cool t-shirts that you can find also on
that website.
And like I said, we love you guys, and
we can't do this without you. God bless.
Keep seeking that truth.